(upbeat music)
- (laughs) Oh my God.
(upbeat music continues)
What was that?
What just came out of his head?
Is it a piercing?
That is my only potential doctorly thing
that I could see happening there.
(upbeat music)
$262,000 at age 17.
Let's see.
(upbeat music intensifies)
Wait, I don't understand.
Did he sell an organ,
get a medical mistake made on him,
therefore suing the practice
and getting medical malpractice?
- [Dan] Do you think he's jazzed
on a medical malpractice
settlement? (laughs)
- I don't know.
Well, he's joking and
he's trying to make it
like he did get surgery to sell an organ.
- [Dan] Yeah, I think it's a job.
(Dan laughing)
- I'm not buying it.
(rhythmical music)
This looks like Exophthalmos,
where the eye actually starts protruding
in front of the eye socket.
Generally, we talk about
this in Graves' disease,
which is a thyroid disorder
where your own body's immune
system starts attacking
certain parts of your body
including the thyroid,
as well as the muscles
surrounding the eye,
which actually force the eye out.
It also could be a congenital variation
where you're just born with
this type of appearance.
- Wrinkles always occur opposite
of how the muscle is laid out.
- Oh, this is good makeup.
- So for example, if you
see the frontalis muscle
goes across your forehead,
(gentle music)
then the wrinkles will go like that.
How do we relax those muscles?
So we need to go with
the muscle, and relax it.
So in the forehead area,
it will be like that.
In the mouth area, it will be like that.
- For massage, I just like it
when people massage my face, period.
I think that's an under massaged
and under-appreciated area,
specifically the masseter muscle.
Like if you massage
this for me, oh my God.
Just try it right now.
As you're watching this video,
try massaging your masseter.
Like while you're masticating.
(gentle music continues)
All right, this is getting weird.
- [Dan] Among the weirdest
things I've ever filmed.
(Doctor Mike laughs)
(rhythmical music)
- (gasps) Is that Bear?
Wow, that's good.
Are they making him a Pokemon?
Did they make him a Pokemon card?
- [Dan] No, I think they just
made his Instagram account.
- Oh, I thought that was a Pokemon card.
What power would Bear
have if he was a Pokemon?
Slobber Attack, and...
Floof Blow.
- Doctor Mike,
you've ruined watching any medical drama
or any medical scene for me
ever in the history of forever.
- That's funny I'm watching my own Tik Tok
on a Tik Tok review.
This is like inception.
I'm reacting to my reaction,
reacting to her reaction,
to my medical drama reactions.
People do tell me I have
ruined medical dramas for them.
At the same time, some people say that
they are now ruining it for
their own family members,
by yelling out, "Chest compressions,
chest compressions, chest compressions",
but that 'Chest compressions'
line has saved lives.
No joke, I get messages
about this all the time.
So yes, I would trade a little decrease
in reputational value for
some of these medical dramas,
for a life saved, or two.
- This video is about to be a thirst trap,
but specifically tailored for nurses.
- Cool.
- You are the under-appreciated backbone
of the medical community
and I want to show you some appreciation.
- Nurses, you get an extra shout out,
but also, medical lab workers,
respiratory therapist attacks,
engineering, clinical engineering staff,
pharmacists, CMAs, environmental staff.
There's so many under-appreciated
medical workers.
Seriously, I want to thank all of you
for the work that you've
done during this pandemic
and always.
(playful music)
(Doctor Mike laughs)
Is it weird that I saw the veins
and the cat at the same time,
and I got equally excited for both?
Just putting a feeler out there,
what would it be like if
Bear had a cat friend?
Bear, if I got you a cat or
a kitten, would you want it?
Are you thinking about it?
Like a little kitty that just
comes in, like plays with you,
might scratch you a little bit at first?
Then I think you guys will get along.
Yeah, you want a little kitty.
Yeah, high five if you want a kitty.
Yeah, you want a kitty.
- Hey, EMS brought in this guy.
BP is crashing MAP's less than 50.
(Doctor Mike laughs)
- I feel like I need to
solely translate this.
EMS, Emergency Medical
Services brought in this guy,
Blood Pressure is crashing,
Mean Arterial Pressure is less than 50.
- Is his O2 sat okay?
- O2 is Oxygen Saturation.
- PMH of COPD?
- Past Medical History
of Chronic Obstructive
Pulmonary Disease. (chuckling)
- PE in the setting of
DVT with underlying IPF.
- Oh, what's IPF?
Nope, but Pulmonary Embolism
in the setting of Deep Vein Thrombosis,
with underlying IPF;
Idiopathic Pulmonary Fibrosis?
- [Dan] That's it.
- No way!
- [Dan] Idiopathic Pulmonary Fibrosis.
- (laughs) I was gonna say
that's such a rare diagnosis.
(Dan mumbles)
- How's the BMP?
- The BMP is the Basic Metabolic Panel.
Okay, now they're just
throwing acronyms around
to throw acronyms around.
- Yeah, he's got CAD.
- He's got CAD, status/ post PCI,
which means he's got
Coronary Arterial Disease,
status post meaning after PCI,
which means a catheterization
with prior CABG meaning
Coronary Arterial Bypass Graft,
it's like open heart surgery,
and HFrEF meaning Heart Failure
with reduced Ejection Fraction
as opposed to Heart Failure
with preserved Ejection Fraction.
- WTF!
- IDK!
- BTW, is your shift almost over?
- LOL, no.
- OMG.
- That was stressful. (laughs)
- [Female Trainer] We're
moving on to a third movement.
Go ahead.
- Okay.
- [Female Trainer] Of
the Moonlight Sonata.
Okay, go ahead.
- I don't know it.
- [Female Trainer] That's fine.
("Moonlight Sonata")
- Wow, that was incredible.
There's something written
there about dementia.
I'm not sure if this patient has dementia
and is still able to play the piano,
because the area for musical recollection
is in a different area of
where we keep the memories,
and our cognitive decisions
day in and day out.
Also, there's a layer of
muscle memory involved there.
This is really cool to see,
and inspiring at the same time.
(gentle music)
- Fun fact, there's actually
only four bands on mouth.
There's just two very large ones
and two thick boys, you know?
- I am not an orthodontist.
I don't know enough about braces
to know why this is happening.
I almost want to like ask
one of my dentist friends
to see why that would be
needed to be instituted.
- Whoa, that's intense.
Your orthodontist is making
uniform outset on your last six,
and here's why.
- Okay, we're gonna get an explanation.
Looks like I don't need to
call my dentist friends.
- [Orthodontist] When you get
towards the end of braces,
your orthodontist will have you
hook up what are called
settling rubber bands
to help the bite fit together better.
Most of the time, we just use them
on the sides of the mouth like this,
but lucky you, your orthodontist
is making you wear them
on all your teeth.
That's a little rough,
but your bite's going to turn out awesome.
- Having an underbite and overbite
can cause problems down the
line in terms of tooth damage,
jaw pain, TMD disorders.
It's funny, I said TMD disorders
when it's actually just TMD
and the D is Disorder. (laughs)
(bright music)
Wow.
(bright music continues)
The pituitary gland
secretes the growth hormone,
which then can affect certain bones.
This is mainly going to happen in areas
outside of the long bones
after you get older,
simply because the
growth plates have fused
in the long bones.
That's why you get a
very specific phenotype,
meaning look, when you
have a pituitary tumor
after your growth plates have fused.
- What's a really weird
thing that your body does
that you're not sure
anybody else's body does?
(upbeat music)
- Oh! (laughs)
(upbeat music continues)
That's actually pretty interesting.
I've never seen that before.
Huh!
(gentle music)
I don't know what to make of that.
There's some kind of just
like cartilage there.
Look, human bodies have all
sorts of variations on them
and that's cool.
That's what makes medicine interesting.
There's patients who have Dextrocardia
where the heart, instead of
being slightly on the left side,
is slightly on the right side.
How cool is that?
- I can confidently say
that I almost died on that hike. (laughs)
I've never seen this in real life before.
My body tried to get me to pee
my pants a number of times.
(sobs) to warm me up.
- If your body senses
that you're losing heat
and it's having trouble
keeping you at a certain temperature,
it's going to divert the
warm blood away from areas
that are not immediately
crucial to your survival
like your lips, like your
fingers, like your toes.
So this blue is dangerous.
The fact that she's shaking so vigorously
is her body desperately trying
to warm up and keep warm.
It's like a form of early hypothermia.
I think you desperately need
to get a reflective blanket
on her, some warmth, turn
on that heat in that car,
and get some fluids in you as well.
(upbeat music)
Oh my God!
I would freak out right now.
(upbeat music continues)
(Doctor Mike laughs)
Did you put this in there
'cause of my spider story?
Oh my God.
I had a beautiful red Audi TTS
and I was driving, and I
stopped at a stop sign,
and as soon as I let go of the brake,
I saw a big green spider.
I saw it and I panicked,
and instead of hitting it
or pushing it away, I
grabbed my wallet and hit it.
Bad idea, because as I
did that, I didn't realize
I also turned the steering
wheel a little bit too far,
without even realizing when I made contact
with the spider, I also made contact
with the front right side of my headlight,
with the back left side of the van
that was parked on the
street across from me,
and I started screaming and crying,
and people came out and they
said, "What are you doing?
You just hit into our car
in the middle of the street
in the middle of the
daytime for no reason".
And I said, "But there was a spider".
Here's the worst part of the story;
calling my Russian angry Soviet father
to tell him that this happened,
and then the firefighters coming
to make sure that I'm okay,
telling them the story and having them
all laugh at me.
(audience laughing)
And then the paramedics and EMTs coming
and hearing the story
(audience laughing)
and laughing at me,
and then calling my insurance company
(laughter continues)
and telling them the story
and having them laugh at me.
I'm not telling that story anymore.
(Nelson laughs)
Shark Tank medical pitches
can sometimes go overboard,
pun intended.
Check out my reviews here,
of some very wild Shark
Tank medical pitches.
And as always, you stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)